- [Mark] Okay, Lindsay.
Lindsay, where have you been?
- [Lindsay] Yes.
- [Mark] I've been looking for you for
like almost three weeks
now since we last spoke.
And you disappeared from Hollywood.
- Yeah.
I went to jail.
- [Mark] You were in jail?
- Yeah.
I--
- [Mark] Can you just be
really brief about what for?
I don't need all the details.
- Yeah.
Assault with a deadly weapon.
- [Mark] Assault with a deadly weapon.
- Yes.
I mean, I went into Popeye's,
and put a knife to somebody's throat.
- [Mark] Why did you do this?
- I was, honestly coming off of drugs and,
I drank a little bit of alcohol.
Then I got angry because, nobody loves me.
I thought that nobody
loved me, but Ben does.
His daughter does and.
- [Mark] And about
300,000 that my viewers.
(laughter)
- Yes.
Yeah.
Thank you guys for all
the comments anyways.
- [Mark] Yeah, she just got out of jail.
- Yeah, I haven't been able to read 'em.
- [Mark] You just got to jail
just, minutes ago, right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Ben and I helped.
Ben is an old friend of yours?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Who I've never met, but he,
he called me out of the blue and said...
You know, I talked to him.
He saw the video and said,
and then I've also been
speaking with your mom
over the last couple of weeks.
- How'd that go?
- [Mark] Very well, I mean very nice.
I mean, she,
we're all kind of on a similar page that,
you know, it seems to me like your
medication is a big part of,
some of your problems.
- Yes.
- [Mark] And if you don't
take them, things go haywire.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It sounds like.
- Yeah, pretty much I mean...
- [Mark] You would agree with that?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It's a common story--
- Yeah, I would.
- [Mark] Down here.
'Cause a lot of the people I'm talking to,
we wanna blame the drugs.
But honestly, the problem
is more of a mental problem.
They're not taking their
medications so they end up taking,
then they take drugs and then
it looks like a drug problem
but it's honestly a mental issue.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So you've been in
jail for almost three weeks?
- Mm hmm.
- [Mark] Two and a half weeks?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And, how was that?
- Jail sucks.
It's very cold, in the suicide dorm.
They ignore you.
Well, they ignored me.
They wouldn't,
give me a grievance or,
a medical paper to speak to the doctors.
They make it very cold
in the room when they,
whenever I told 'em I was anemic.
They, mistreat you very
bad in the dorm 1202.
1201's not so bad.
But 1403 is the mental place.
I was supposed to get my clothes back
but they never gave 'em back to me.
Don't know why but, whatever.
I mean, a lot of stuff escalated
towards me going to jail.
Like, almost being raped.
I kinda, almost did get raped, actually.
If I wouldn't have put my
knee up against his chest
and pushed him off and then just like
clocked him in the head,
he wouldn't have, and then screamed,
he wouldn't have left me alone.
I stayed in a tent with a
guy that was going to hurt me
because, he had a knife and I said,
"Hey, can I
can I hold your knife because
something don't feel right."
So he gave me his knife.
That night, he went to sleep
and I stayed up all night.
If I hadn't have had that knife,
this guy would've came in and hurt us
because this guy that I didn't know,
poked his head in the tent.
And I swamped, I switched out
the switchblade and I said,
"Get the fuck out."
And, he got pissed off.
So he took all the money by
the door of the tent and left.
And then whenever my friend woke up,
I told him what happened.
And he was mad because
all the money was gone.
- [Mark] Life on the
street is, crazy like that.
- Yeah, it is crazy.
The same guy, whenever I
try to get away from him,
before, when he had his knife
which led up to this story
that I just told you,
this little tidbit that I just told you,
he, I tried to get away
from him one night.
And I was walking Hollywood Boulevard
tryna stay on camera, tryna stay in sight.
I went into, in front of the
cameras of Hard Rock Cafe.
I went in front of every
camera that I could find,
and he was following me so I had to like,
keep a good eye out on him and,
change sides of the street.
I got away from that.
And then I took his knife.
- [Mark] And this happened the night after
you and I spoke, right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] The same day?
- Oh yeah.
Well, no, actually.
Wait, yes.
Yes, it did.
- [Mark] I think it was.
According to your mom.
- I'm sorry?
- [Mark] According to your mom
'cause she had the date
of the arrest and then
I looked at the data of
video, it's the same day.
- Yeah.
My mom doesn't know anything about
how I'm doing out here
other than through Ben.
I wish she'd just leave me
the fuck alone, honestly.
I really do.
Yeah, I'm fucking sick of her
stalking me and trying to find
out everything, little bitty,
every little thing about my life.
Mom I'm fucking sick of you,
leave me the fuck alone.
- [Mark] What would you like
to see happen for, Lynne?
Like from here on out?
- Me?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I would love to just
like, maybe go to rehab,
get a social worker,
get my own place and start my life.
That's what I would like to see happen.
I mean, I would go to
rehab because, you know?
People can't just stop
thinking about drugs.
You just, don't stop
thinking about it, you know?
You gotta go to rehab and get help.
- Yeah, I think there were actually
quite a few comments from
people that run rehabs and therapists
and all kinds of people that
offered up their services to you.
So maybe on this video, we can kinda,
get in touch with some of those people.
(deep exhaling)
(scratching sounds)
What do you think the chances
are of you sticking with a
recovery program and just
following through?
- The chances of that
are very good.
Because I feel I need it.
- [Mark] That's great,
are you clean right now?
'Cause you've been in
jail for three weeks.
- Yeah, I am.
I mean, would I go back
out there and do drugs?
No, but I still think I need rehab.
- [Mark] Yeah, no I--
- In order to get a social worker.
In order to get my own place.
The night that,
actually, the same day
that you gave me the
money for the previous interview.
- [Mark] Yes.
- I went to buy alcohol with it.
And I was in a frantic
mindset because nobody,
like I said, nobody gave a shit about me.
So,
I tried to buy alcohol and I accidentally
tried to buy it with my
food stamps card one time.
And then I accidentally tried to buy it
with my social security one time.
Because I never have cash.
I never had money in hand.
So I'm not used to having money in hand.
- [Mark] Well, Ben seems
like a good friend.
- He is.
- [Mark] He's gonna let you
stay with him for a few days,
at least?
- Hopefully my court date's tomorrow.
- [Mark] Oh, your court date's tomorrow?
- Yep.
- [Mark] Well, it's good that you're out.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I think--
- I mean right now, I
think all I need to do is,
well, all I want to do right now,
'cause I don't know how jail's gonna go.
I just wanna smoke a blunt and eat.
And just chill in a bed.
That's all I wanna do.
- [Mark] You could probably
do two or three of those.
Maybe all three.
At Ben's, I'm sure.
- Hopefully.
I wanna go back to Hollywood.
- [Mark] You wanna go back to the streets?
- Not in the streets.
I just wanna walk around
the Hollywood Boulevard.
- [Mark] Oh, okay yeah.
Well that's,
as long as you don't end
up in the same kind of...
- As long as I'm not
there in the nighttime,
I think I'll be all right.
Because it gets cold at night.
And I'm anemic, so I can't
really just sleep on the streets
with no blanket.
- [Mark] Mm hmm.
- I have to be in a
tent or have a blanket.
Or walk around all night
and deprive myself of sleep
and maybe sleep in the sun.
But that's what the
bracelets in jail look like.
- [Mark] How?
So how, tell me about jail.
What was the worst part?
- I think the worst part was
being cold and being mistreated.
- [Mark] And probably coming
off the drugs too, right?
- Yeah,
kinda, yeah.
Yeah.
- [Mark] You've been in jail before?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And,
that time, was it also like
your medications might've been
off or something you weren't taking
that may have triggered that?
- The first time I went
to jail in Florida,
I wasn't on any medication.
Actually, I would just come home drunk
and get something to eat
and try to go to my room.
And my mom would aggravate me.
To the fullest extent.
To the point where I would throw my food
or yell or something because
I'm believe I'm autistic.
And she would, she never
leaves me the fuck alone.
And then I get to call,
the cops called on me.
And then I'd go to jail
just because she doesn't want me home
or she needs a break
or some shit like that.
Instead of just telling me to get out.
- [Mark] She has a shed for you.
So she showed me a picture
of, in her backyard.
- Who, a shed?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I'm not going back home.
Why the fuck should I
have to stay in a shed?
Why can't I stay in the house, you know?
- [Mark] I'm just, gonna
show you the message that
she wanted me to tell you.
- Oh, okay.
I mean, unless it's a brand new shed
and unless it's in my name,
and unless I'm left the fuck alone, maybe.
But other than that, no.
- [Mark] Well, now that you're out,
you guys can probably speak.
- I don't know if I'll speak to her again.
I might.
I don't know.
- [Mark] The rehab, you think is
what is it?
Is it the alcohol, is it
drugs, is it the whole thing?
Is it, tell me what you think is.
- Rehab, it's,
I don't know.
I'll go for whatever they
think I need to go for.
- [Mark] And then they'll
probably figure that out.
- Yeah.
I mean, Ben is nice enough
to let me stay with him, so.
- [Mark] Yeah, he seems like a nice guy.
- He is.
- [Mark] When I listened to
your story the first time,
what I heard, and I'm not,
I don't claim to be an expert, but,
it reminded me of like
when I was maybe your age.
And there were times where I just,
could not love myself.
I just refused, I just
couldn't get a handle
on loving myself.
So you end up having these
really dark thoughts.
And then, you know,
that's just part of it,
you know, growing up and maturing and
the age you're at, you're 26?
- Mm hmm.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And I see my daughters,
who are younger than you slightly but,
going through similar kind of emotions.
And I almost think it's
part of humans growing up.
And as we age, we mellow a little bit.
But it doesn't make the pain
that you're in any less.
It is what it is.
- You wanna know what I think?
- [Mark] What do you think?
- I think that nobody
should have to grow up.
(laughter)
I'm not gonna grow up.
I mean, just 'cause I have a job
and shit in the house and everything,
I'm not gonna grow up.
- [Mark] Yeah, well that's
a healthy attitude too.
That's
- Why grow up?
- [Mark] Yeah.
I'm a lot older than you
and I still feel like I'm 20 years old.
I still think I am.
- I mean, my mom would
love to see me grow up.
Maybe that's why I don't wanna grow up.
She would love to see me blonde.
Maybe that's why I wanna
die all of my hair black.
- [Mark] Your hair's--
- She'd love to see me in pink
but I'm not gonna be in pink.
- [Mark] What color is
your hair naturally?
- Blonde.
(laughter)
- [Mark] Oh really?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It's funny.
You seem like your hair should be dark.
- Yeah.
It makes it look fuller, you know?
- [Mark] Well, it just suits you.
I mean it's like, I can't
even imagine you as a blonde.
Well, I'd love to help
you out in some way.
I guess we should just
see how the hearing goes.
Tomorrow, is it?
Tomorrow?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Let's see how
that goes and then we'll,
go from there.
- Okay.
- [Mark] But,
I think my viewers would love to help you.
I would love to help you.
I think it's pretty much--
- Thank you, guys.
- [Mark] It's been very kind.
A lot of lovely
very supportive viewers that really care.
We wanna see you do better.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Okay then, well,
thank you for coming back and,
hey, we'll talk again after your hearing.
We'll see how that goes.
- Okay.
- [Mark] All right.
Great to see you.
- Right.
- [Mark] Thanks.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Awesome.